this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
a series of events called the menstrual
cycle happens about once every month to
prepare a woman's body for pregnancy
changing levels of natural chemicals in
the bloodstream called hormones control
these events
the reproductive organs affected by
these hormones include the vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
the ovaries produce two main hormones
called estrogen and progesterone
as the level of estrogen begins to rise
it causes the normally thick mucus
inside the cervix to thin out
estrogen also triggers other hormones to
cause one of the ovaries to release an
egg
this process is called ovulation
if a woman has sex during this time a
man's reproductive cells called sperm
can pass through the thinner mucus to
fertilize an egg
in the uterus estrogen causes the lining
to thicken which prepares it to receive
a fertilized egg
rising progesterone levels cause glands
in the lining to release fluid that
feeds the fertilized egg
progesterone also causes the thinned out
mucus in the cervix to become thick
again which prevents sperm from passing
through
if an egg hasn't been fertilized the
levels of both estrogen and progesterone
begin to fall
this drop in hormone levels causes
menstruation
a process where the uterus sheds its
inner tissue lining and blood through
the vagina
a progestin implant is a form of birth
control or contraception it prevents
pregnancy for up to three years
the device is implanted under the skin
in a woman's upper arm
a progestin implant is a matchstick size
flexible plastic rod containing a
progesterone-like hormone called
progestin
it's designed to be able to show up on
x-rays
the implant continually releases
progestin in the body
progestin levels help prevent the body
from releasing other hormones that cause
ovulation
without ovulation there is no egg
available for fertilization so a woman
can't get pregnant
a second way progestin prevents
pregnancy involves its effect on the
mucus in the cervix high progesterone
levels keep the mucus in the cervix
thick enough so sperm can't get through
it
a third way progestin prevents pregnancy
involves its influence on the lining of
the uterus
in contrast to natural progesterone
progestin is slightly different
chemically
over time it makes the uterine lining
thinner instead of thicker
as a result if fertilization of an egg
does take place the lining may be too
thin for it to stay in the uterus so it
passes out of the body with the next
menstrual period
a doctor can insert a progestin implant
during an office visit
to do this the doctor will make two
marks with a sterile marker
one for the insertion site and a second
mark used as a direction guide during
insertion
then the insertion area will be cleaned
with an antiseptic
and numbed with a local anesthetic
next the doctor will use a special
applicator to puncture the skin with a
hollow needle containing the implant and
slide it beneath the skin
finally the needle will be removed
leaving the implant behind
after the implant is placed the doctor
will ensure proper placement by feeling
for both ends of the implant under the
skin
a bandage will be placed over the
insertion site
menstrual bleeding with a progestin
implant may include changes in bleeding
frequency bleeding intensity
and duration of each bleeding period
although the implant can be removed
sooner it must be removed after three
years
a doctor can replace it with a new
implant at that time
if pregnancy is suspected it's important
for a woman to see her healthcare
provider the implant may need to be
removed
a progestin implant is over 99 effective
at preventing pregnancy
this means less than one out of a
hundred women will become pregnant each
year using this form of birth control
for more information on any type of
birth control talk to your health care
provider